hey what's up it's your boy Julio Goos
hey what up man it's your boy little Uno
the Boogeyman and check out the bootleg
Kev podcast let's go yay hey this
interview is brought to you by our good
Folks at Imperial extractions ladies and
gentlemen now check this out if you want
a free 2 G pre-roll delivered right to
your door they got you go get a free 2 G
thca Diamond infused pre-roll with any
order right now we're talking about 1
and2 gram of top shell flour and a half
a gram of pure TCA diamonds Imperial
extraction. promo code bootleg and
you're going to get this for free
delivered right to your door let's get
to the
interview yo bootle C podcast man
special guests in here two of them my
guy go toes hey hey what's happening
what's happening Mr Little One AKA Uno
yo yo yo yo glad to be here we got the
Bay in San Diego in the building right
now yeah what's going on first of all
why yall G one more the Bay in San Diego
yeah the West Coast baby yeah wh what
brings you guys here together um we got
a few things man uh he had just wrote a
song that I uh that he wrote for we
didn't write you know he wrote a song
for me I said man I want to I want to do
something different and he had a track
man and I was like man I'm feeling that
one let me get on that and uh he blessed
me with the writing and uh I got up on
there and it came out really good so
it's a new song called wake up actually
we're going to be at KDAY today we're
going to Fe of the song Wait so you're
rapping yeah yeah I'm rapping on there
how long have GTO been rapping gto's
been rapping yeah well you know I don't
oh I saw old school like album cover of
yours right yeah yeah yeah yeah that so
this is so this is not new to you nah
nah n it ain't new to me but but but
what I say I don't consider myself a
rapper I'm a reciter man I'm I have fun
because people got to write the raps for
me so I just take the words you know and
and do what I do have some fun with it
that's what music is about CU you if you
put album out back in the day right yeah
the Gold Rush how long ago was that uh
sh about 18 years ago [__] yeah I think
people see you as like an executive OG
well I was I and when I when I did black
and brown entertainment I was I was an
executive for the first you know almost
10 years of it before I even hit the mic
the first song I did ever was the walk
on toes with South Park Mexican and that
that hook he did he wrote the hook that
that thing was all over the radio he's
uh definitely in the headlines a lot
even though despite being in jail yeah
you going to stay in the headlines what
is your take on kind of like that whole
situation there's it seems as if people
have like a hard Line in the Sand in the
Lettin hip hop Community where they're
either like you know [__] him if you're
associated with him I don't know like it
just feels like I don't I don't know I'm
not fully educated on what happened with
him right I just know he got convicted
you know right but what is your thought
process on on controversy currently I
mean he's just when like I always say
when he gets out he's just going to have
to speak on it and you
know that's a really all I got to say
about when he gets out he's going to
he's going to get so much shows you
would think N I don't know man I don't
know me I don't know cuz you're going to
have uh you know it ain't going to just
happen like that they're going to have
stipulations I'm sure you know what I
mean especially with that those type of
charges that's fair you know um what
about you man what's going on with uh
with Uno well like you said uh you know
the Cho music festivals everything to me
but beyond the artist standpoint it's
just connecting the dots into the
culture and that's kind of how me and
Goos just kind of came together
symmetrically and just organically you
know what I'm saying besides the music
so when we did that song we started
sharing more music we we spent more time
together and I ended up doing a a two
album deal yeah I let me me say
something I really
like uh I didn't when I started really
getting into his music I he started
sending me all these songs from me you
know and I started bumping I'm like I
started going into I'm like man oh man
he gets down you know and I and I like
the odies and he he was flipping them
tight I'm like oh he got something you
know what I'm saying and I was I don't
know did you think I was going to be
able to flip that song when I did it
yeah so so when he's like yo let's do
this song like you you heard goto goto
got natural right natural spit natural
flow you know so when uh when he asked
me I'm like absolutely you could do that
then you know we got the lyrics out
there and then one day he just hit me
and the song was done wow I got it done
quick too like in a couple hours you
know yeah for people who don't know Uno
you're kind of like um you're like one
of the ogs in the Cho rap world the
pioner how long have you been at this
cuz well well my first album once in a
decade came out in
1996 [__] you know 96 and then and then
I was N I got to you know what's crazy I
had a 9-year-old the other day uh when I
was in Reno and he was saying now this
could have been what homicide or maybe
this could have been suicide from Once
in a decade and he's nine and he's nine
that's crazy right but I mean you know
I've always I've always felt that you
know the whole Cho rap thing that's cool
but I never really seen it that way I've
always seen music like you was saying
like art like no no color no age No No
Label I've I've always looked at music
like freedom and that and and and so has
Goos and I think that's what's been able
to to align us you know not necessarily
thinking in in a box when it comes to
your crowd your audience yeah yeah like
you know we for the culture and
everything but ultimately man like the
magnitude of what we're doing is freedom
yeah I always tell tell people like I
think um you know growing up cuz I'm
from Phoenix right so we had magic and
MB Riders and nasty boy click before
they MB Riders and all that but like I
listened to uh what was Co show Poco SP
Loos [__] I used to be the board op and
all that [__] I used to go to all the
low rider shows so I was like very hip
to the culture but the music necessarily
didn't ever really like a lot of the Cho
rap [__] was like very hey this is for
us you know what I'm saying yeah and and
don't get me wrong and and it is but I
mean that doesn't like there is more
than than samp there's more than that
yeah it's more than just sampling a song
and rapping no there [__] that I was
like a fan of too yeah like you know
everybody expects it to sound like Simon
right when there really is like
skeletons being made out of these
Melodies remedies made to make memories
you know what I'm saying yeah and then
like I think some of the high power guys
are dropping [__] with like bizy bone
like and and yeah but like there's real
MC's too like shadows and MC Kos and MC
you know there's real MC's too but I
always felt that we were so much more
you know I think bash did a good job of
breaking that door down to be like hey I
happen to be Latin but I'm making party
music that if you live in New York flid
you still bang it out right you can
still bang it out and it's it's still
the same thing synonymously with the
festival like you know the festival
consists of all the cultural elements
but it's just a door for everyone to
come through and experience the culture
for sure you know what I'm saying that's
happening on S Deo on CCO de Mayo sgo
it's going to be crazy yeah
Legacy the midnighter slck and the
wicked D phonic jayrock Pia K Shadow
it's going to be crazy coyote yeah
they're dope gold toes I'm going be up
in the house you know gold toes coming
through we got man we got a whole bunch
of stuff lined up like I said man you
know got a whole layout man yeah we got
a whole layout you know I signed a two
album deal with him the English album
will be El Cho and the Spanish album is
El Mexicano and you know and then we got
a joint project that we working on
together as well that would be hard so
you know we got a lot of music we got a
lot of visuals we got a lot of shows we
got a lot of a lot com to I want to give
you props because I feel like you've
been very instrum instrument in terms of
uh Bridging the Gap
between Southern California Northern
California Latinos M yeah you know we're
just communicating with each other uh a
lot more conversations are happening uh
naturally you know what I'm saying uh uh
you know and more to come um you know
it's it's going to take some time but
you know you know it's good to
communicate and and get on to another uh
you know far future I was going to say
do you think like in terms of like where
that like just kind of the relationships
of like certain artists with certain
artists from from up north or down south
or even guys like like you like who
you've worked with like like 10 years
ago would any of that stuff have been
possible five years ago cuz it feels
like there's been a lot more putting
some of the politic [__] to the side and
just kind of uniting on on yeah I mean
no it wouldn't have been possible I mean
it could have but I mean it would have
just been a lot more uh it would it
would have been a lot more I would say
um more complicated and difficult I
think through the times now and what's
going on uh uh in the last few years
within the prison system I believe has
helped out um things to help develop
things in the streets and um you know
there's a lot of Latins that are not
into no type of gangs or no type of
politics that that still feel subject to
uh where they're from yeah just to that
and geographically yeah geographically
and there needs to be some type of now
you know yeah we giving it we're giving
it a chance to we're giving ourselves a
chance to shine a little bit and to work
to work together you know what I'm
saying so you know it's going to take
some time uh you know and it's happening
yeah it's happening right now you in
your podcast you know and I and again I
think I think beyond anything I think
the the thing that's important here is
not we're not trying to do anything
that's just transactional we want to do
things that are
transformational you know what I'm
saying and that's the energy that we're
on you know be be Beyond just music like
you know really building something a
found that comes from a foundation of
Purity mhm you know like this is this
isn't just about a monetary gain it's
it's much more than that set an example
yeah when we got together we were like
oh you're from over it it it connected
connect clicked it right away you know
say we we have and we have a lot in
common so um everything's just coming in
it's coming how it's supposed to be we
coming at it how it's supposed to come I
wanted to go to go back and give a shout
out to pocp Locos cuz that was a
yeah cuz I mean they put on a lot of
Laos from everywhere I think our tacos
man this guy's hey
man bro we're in the middle of theast
where you
at the door locked the door is locked a
[__] okay cus give us the W go my bad
gra take my phone man my bad okay we're
on the wi he got us on the wide angle we
could keep he been calling me and
calling I'm like [__]
man okay tell them you're coming no I
was going to say uh yeah no pocos P Loos
obviously like I feel like Kool-Aid I
forget the DJ's name he up he they did a
lot for the culture for sure man a lot
you know I remember Kool-Aid was a very
big believer in it the big bad Network
you know yeah and you know he grew up in
Oxnard you know the Oxnard is heavy with
the culture sh out to the 805 man yeah
shout out to the 805 and you know
Kool-Aid opened that door and we came
and the more they got syndicated that
the more we got out there so that was a
good plug for us yeah and those low
those OG low rider shows were crazy I'm
talking about like 6 05 07 yanking and
cranking you know what I'm saying um
tell me kind of like uh for people who
don't know you have GT digital which is
your distribution Distribution Company
yep and these days there's so many
distribution companies popping up right
everybody's trying to do it a lot of
people try to do it they just can't get
clients well that's what I was going to
say for you like uh cuz I'm really you
know obviously I'm real type with gazi
and Ne and those guys and as as you are
you do a lot of business with Empire as
well there's companies like um Dro kid
to cor and one RPM and so many
independent Distributors these days uh
what is the what do you bring to the
table that is unique I think that being
my my years of being in the record
business you know black and brown
entertainment this Latin records knowing
how to be a record label and the the the
necessity of communication dealing with
the artist people do want to give you
their life of their heart and then all
of a sudden you got to talk to an email
and you can't speak to nobody you know
with us I have a staff we're going to
talk to you I talk to you I listen to
the music I'm I'm in tune with everybody
and there's a lot of artists out there
you know what I'm saying but I I'm able
to uh decipher who really wants it and
who is necessary of that time to talk to
him of course everybody is and we do I
believe there's enough time in our day
to talk to everybody that's the whole
thing I don't you know we want to talk
to you I Le give you five minutes to
chop it up with you see what's going on
how are you doing with your marketing
what do you need help in let me listen
to your best song first thing I do
what's your best song right what's your
best video let me see it you know what I
mean that ain't nothing this is what I'm
doing I'm in the music business I want
to listen to the music you know there's
some people that there's up companies
that don't do none of that that is true
you got to send an email you gotta yeah
that's it D your kid ain't listening to
your [__] t no no for sure you think
them [__] they is not listening
to your [__] they don't give you you
just loading it up putting it in you
going to get they goingon to get their
money they going to pay you that is it
hard though like uh trying to be
accessible to
everybody you know what actually it
ain't nah yeah they a because most
people most I'm going to say most
artists are only doing an album or
two so they they're putting they some
some mother they forget about they even
put something up right you know what I'm
saying then you got some that are
seriously into it and then you you could
talk to them they're going to put
something out I mean it's it's you know
like I said 10-minute conversation is
going to go a long way yeah I think
that's what he does different you know
because like he was talking about the
communication I think when there's
communication with comprehension it
changes the dynamic of just
communicating when you communicate with
comprehension you understand what you're
talking about and I think he's really
good at that he's really good at letting
them know like look this is a b and c
this is the way it's supposed to happen
you do your part I do my part everybody
wins instead of like oh my shit's out
all over the you know in every platform
right so what hey what up y'all I'm
excited because I'm going to be flying
to Tampa to DJ the odd Sox holiday party
next week and of course as y'all know
odd Sox are OG sponsors our family the
most comfortable socks in the world want
to give much love to odd Soxs for always
holding us down at the bleake C podcast
now it is the holiday season there ain't
nothing like getting you a pair of odd
Soxs for your loved one getting some
underwear getting a hat whatever you're
into they got at oddsocks official.com
promo code bootleg save 20% off 20% off
at checkout right now all the licenses
WWE uh I mean
Hooters oh some hooters underwear let's
take a peek at these huh
bunch of [__] owls all over you there
we
go I like it what about Chucky ain't
nothing like some Chucky socks during
the Christmas you know hey whatever
you're into they got it oddsocks
official.com use the promo code bootleg
right now save 20% off uh and enjoy the
most comfortable socks in the world also
want to give a shout out to our family
over there King pal now nice to think
about King
pal what I love about King pom no
tobacco no nicotine we're talking about
about
straight natural Leaf organic Leaf all
right and and and the cool thing is they
got these tpping infused tips when I
tell you they're turpine infused I mean
it like I love these ones shout out to
uh sugar Shan sugar Shan [__] I almost
[__] his name up uh sugar Shan Ali
from Phoenix uh he's got his honey
orange here how it works you load that
thing up with your cannabis flow you got
that flavorful tip
inside bam that's what it looks like
when it's all done it's like a work of
art ladies and gentlemen it's a work of
art all right go to your local smoke
shop wherever you're at they got King
pom go ask for King pom thank me later
okay King pom local smoke shop 7-Eleven
they got them or you can just go to the
website check this out go to the website
king pom.com take care of somebody in
your life that you love and get 50% off
everything you order at King pom.com
using the promo code bootleg 50% off
that's half off half off king pom.com
that's what we're doing right now all
right let's get back to the interview
yeah the dro game is interesting because
I just see I feel like every major label
has their own version of I guess what
Empire I feel like kind of
revolutionized in terms of like you know
they kind of kicked the door down and
now everybody everybody's got their own
empire under their umbrella you know
like 300 has Sparta and you know go on
and on and on so I just always been
wondering like you know I just I'm
intrigued by the business me and gazi
both started off with ingros back
I was I started I started I started in
gr's rap division was their first rap I
was their first rap label Maxi hooked up
gazi with them for the job for him to
get in there that's crazy you know what
I'm saying gazi was you know my engineer
for black and brown entertainment at
that time you know what I'm saying so I
mean we go he's still engineering too he
just engineered the whole album you know
it's the true cuz like there's there's a
uh YouTube video of gazi saying I want
to be like hulio when I grow up I'm like
now gazi blew up that mean all this to
say is at any point you could get you
can blow it could take one day any point
man in this game it could happen you
know dreams can happen overnight over
with the you know stuff goes viral all
of a sudden boom you're on I was going
to ask both of you guys cuz you guys
each have had so much independent
success in the rap game I feel like I
always correlate the Bay Area with like
just the the real roots of this
independent rap [__] like getting it out
the trunk you know what I'm saying yeah
how do you guys like being on both sides
of the game right like in
2023 the music game so different there's
got to be like other ways to monetize
your music besides the streaming cuz
streaming is you know it is what it is I
mean cross marketing of course with
other artists you know what I'm saying
paying for you know getting ads YouTube
ads Tik Tok ads doing marketing you got
to spend money got to spend money man
you know and it may not come back you
know at least you gave your at least you
gave it a shot to shine though and you
got to be okay with that yeah you got to
be okay you got to be that's acceptance
of that is a huge part of being an
artist m you know what I'm saying I i'
I've always been a firm believer of that
like sometimes deepo choa says
expectancy determines outcomes when
you're not attached to the outcome the
outcome is guaranteed sometimes that
desire and that want creates an actual
barrier between you and your success I
think you know of course doing your
visuals
too it's the truth I think your visuals
too you got to get in you you got to get
creative with your videos and your
visuals you know what I'm saying yeah
sometimes the you think is the one may
not be and you got to be okay with that
and you got to be okay gamble bro
everything this is all the gamble that's
why I say like I have fun with this [__]
man like when he wrote the song having
fun with I'm going to go do a video we
having fun that's what I do with my
music that's how I enjoy it if I spend I
go spend 10 20,000 [__] if I don't make
it back at least I have fun doing that
ask when he told me about the music I
was like ah bro that's like fifth on the
list for me yeah you know what I'm
saying cuz it is you know I'm the
bringing the culture together doing
these festivals all over the country you
know closing that paradoxic divided SL
divided Gap yeah I mean you've been
doing your thing as a promoter for a
long time a long time yeah which is an
whole other side of the game is yeah you
know but again resource and strategy you
know there have been some shows that
didn't go so well so what there's been
some shows that were phenomenal yeah
there's some records that didn't do so
well so what there's some records that
did phenomenal yeah I've been on Power
106 I've been in Boise like you know it
doesn't matter
you know every single aspect of what you
do to contribute to what you're doing
matters you know what I'm saying so I
think a lot of artists have this idea
this fallacy of what they're they're
dreaming and there ain't nothing wrong
with that but ultimately you can't let
money consume you it's got you got to
have passion for what you do you got to
have passion for your art you still got
one of the things that people say about
Floyd Mayweather is that he was still
training like he was broke for sure you
know what I'm saying like the passion
has to be your purpose your art I always
look at music like art that's why it
comes so naturally I've been doing it
for a long time but I was never like a
ABC person just to do songs to do songs
right especially as I got older and
especially as life itself became more
meaningful to me relationships become
more meaningful you magnetize and Ally
with other people that are living a
meaningful life and then whatever you do
becomes meaningful so therefore it
happens organically yeah Goos I wanted
to ask you and obviously you had a lot
to do with this too uh just with the
name of your label uh but why do you
think that Northern California it feels
like black artists and Latin artists are
more privy and naturally working
together cuz I feel like when it comes
to Southern California it feels it feels
like the rap game is a little more
divided it's just the way we grew up in
the bay and in Northern Cali it's just
you know we grew up black and brown I
mean even La they grew up black and
brown too but they think you know just I
think from you know that's obviously
changing but I just mean like
historically it just feels like a little
more like different like I think it's
just in the bay it's always been like
that you know the blacks and the
Mexicans we grew up together so it's
just always had that we've had that that
uh how can I say the lingo you know what
I'm saying San Francisco you know it's a
little different that's all it's just
what it is it's just different you know
right geographically we raise different
we we interact differently and um you
know that's it really at the end of the
day uh how you feeling about San
Francisco man I feel like every time I
go back and everybody moving out it's
like what the [__] happened to my city
everybody gone got bums everywhere I
mean the city's still a city but hey the
Chinese president came through and they
clean that [__] up hey fris hey fris man
n fris you know City still a city but
you know a lot of everybody been moving
out uh you know hitting the suburbs or
moving to different states but at the
end of the day man you know I love my
city every time I go there I'm just
paranoid I'm just like everyone take
everything out of your car you let's not
get bipped we doing the Splash City you
know me and B got we doing the SP with
four ways entertainment so I met him I
was at his compound uh couple months ago
and I met the guys who I think help
wrote it they they came through yeah I
think the trailer just dropped right
yeah we just dropped the trailer yeah
when that coming it's going to be coming
out hopefully uh we're going to start
filming in January so sometime by the
end of the year 2024 yeah cuz I think
burn was saying this like you know if
you think about all like these Netflix
series and like gangster movies there's
never been like anything that's really
there's been Boston gangster movies New
York gangster movies there ain't never
been no like real Spotlight on the Bay
and like what goes on in the bay and
there's so much culture there there's so
much like man it's it's about their time
it's our time to shine you feel yeah
that's why we're here dog Building
Bridges everywhere even the Mexicans in
Texas different than the Mexicans in
California trust me I just went hog
hunting with that Mexican oh yeah I saw
that yeah and that was uh fun but you
see building a bridge like you said from
the bay to to here here to Texas and
even California and Texas to Mexico
right the the Mexico the movement with
music is crazy right now going nuts for
sure it's crazy so that's what me and
goto's doing we here Building Bridges
just putting our resources together and
communicating and see what we can make
happen you know and it's good for the
culture it's good for all of us for sure
what do you guys think of a guy like
Mexican OT who is [__] he just got a
gold record he's I think he make iten I
think he's Savage I think I think he's a
dope you see how fast he popped up boom
you know what I'm saying but he said
exactly like how Goos was talking about
about the N word and he's like it's just
culture yeah like where he was raised he
was raed that's is where we grew up man
it just Co I went to a city where he
grew up I saw it you know yeah Texas
Texas Texas you know they got a lot of
slang out there they saying they got a
lot of slang Ian we Mexicans out there
sound black black I thought we sound
black in a b I'm like damn you sound
more black than me yo yeah Texas is wild
everybody got a strap we were cracking
out there Manas we were in the middle of
nowhere just stalking
hogs on a helicopter no no we did and
then we did it on foot at like 2:00 in
the morning with night vision and [__]
it was [__] crazy yeah but that was
dope I'm sure that's a different
experience that's how he grew up yeah
for sure you know that's what makes it
dope where do you guys put a guy like uh
Magic in the pantheon of like Latin hip
hop cuz he obviously he makes love music
but he's also MC Magic like yeah but in
my opinion I mean you know I love I love
the freedom of his art he stayed true to
his roots he you know he he he he gets
music and provides his art to the music
and everybody hears a MC Magic beat and
knows it's MC he's doing more shows now
than he's ever done in his career that's
what's so crazy and the fans are getting
hey so is
Bash doing it together him bash and
little Rober running it up running it
up they're doing more shows than they
ever done and it's crazy cuz like like
they'll s sell out the Nova like twice a
year year you know what I'm saying like
it's just it's just wild cuz I always
feel like magic like for us in a he's
like kind of like the [__] biggest
thing that's ever come out of Phoenix
you know what I mean so there some but I
mean he's always treated that music like
art for sure and he's always been a
professional always always I got him
ontin lock Downs yeah yeah you know I
just saw him in San Diego uh maybe a few
months ago when he was out there
shooting the video and we chopped it up
for a little bit but he's also a really
good dude the best hey we got to stop
the interview real quick man shout out
to our family at my bookie NFL season is
winding down you still got some regular
season uh games you can get in on of
course the college bowl games are coming
up so much money to get plus the cash
priz is going down in their weekly
Blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy because
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at my bookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$11,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl gam so
much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet any time anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our good folks over at
blueo make sure you go over to blue.com
right now a lot of people asking me yo
man blueo does that [__] work yeah it
works man find out for yourself though
blueo is legit same active ingredient as
viag seis but if you want to know if it
works they're going to take care of you
with your first month for free by using
the promo code bootleg at blu.com
that's right blu.com use that promo code
bootleg and get your first month for
free free this is how it goes down no
awkward doctor's visits none of that if
you're dealing with a rectile
dysfunction you're dealing with too much
stress maybe you're drinking a little to
much you get the whiskey dick I don't
know huh Blu got you all right blu.com
promo code bootleg sign up right now get
your first month supply for free
delivered right to your doorstep for
only $5 in shipping no uh doctor's
appoint it's all online discret
packaging in a blue chewable form come
on fellas it's getting cold outside
let's make sure those [__] stay hard
all right let's get back to interview
and like he's got uh you know he's kind
of taking a page from your book and he's
doing his own shows yeah he's doing his
own shows too you know like it's crazy
cuz if you go to a magic
show he's on like if if Rob's opening or
someone's opening for him like or anyone
that goes on before like he's on the
side of the stage running the show yeah
like I was standing there with him I was
like oh you're [__] like handling the
like he's playing the graphics on the
screen and [__] [__] like don't you have
someone who can do this like so that you
know when I was doing the lock down I
was getting him on the show then I seen
him doing his thing too but you know
even even just being motivated to do the
festival because of things like that you
know there's a lot of people that use
the word Taco the word michelada the
word tamale and just add Festival to it
for sure and you know I went we Myst did
one in Fresno I think it was like called
Taco
Throwdown you know there's there's
millions of dollars being generated off
the culture you know what I'm saying so
for so why not let why not I mean shout
out to Bobby D too who's do
on the big concert Bob got pluma he's
[__] murder but you know like that's
the objective here the objective is is
beyond that I mean you know there's
always this microscopic [__] lens in
the inner city like nobody gives it the
telescopic lens about the beautiful [__]
that happens in the culture you know
what I'm saying so bringing acts like
Tiera and like Malo and Del phonics cuz
the all these are a part of the culture
for sure have you uh obviously you're HP
to like what Desi hollow's doing
Oceanside doing a great job with the old
school yeah yeah for sure he's dop as
[__] too and I got OED Pia you know he's
dope as [__] too but again you know
being able to bring the the mtown side
of it the Latino side of it the hip-hop
side of it with little weirdo coyote and
still got K and Shadow you know and uh
and just being a being weirdo do too I
got to get him on the show weirdo's dope
yeah weirdo's dope you know and connect
connecting with Goos you know man and
being able to do we want to take this to
the Bay we want to take this to Texas
goto I was going to ask you what do you
think is like a key to kind of helping
some of these uh like like smaller
cities in the middle of Cali cuz I think
of a guy like GB who have had on the
show shout out to him Ghetto Boy uh but
there's like cities like Fresno there's
cities like Bakersfield there's cities
like Stockton Stockton's booming right
now they they they got to cross Market
themselves I mean you can even I mean
even when I mean there's a lot of
rappers and you could be cracking
locally but I'm going to be honest you
got to get out you even got to get out
the state to start moving around I mean
most of these guys they put out an album
they ain't even making $110,000 in a
year they're most of them probably
making about three racks at the most I
mean it's like for real you feel me well
I mean yeah especially if you start
doing the math on the streaming yeah I
started seeing you know they you think
they popping but they really when you
start really seeing the
numbers probably made about four grand
last year you know if you got a million
streams it's like $3,700 keep going man
you got to keep pushing you feel me so
uh you know you got music like I tell
everybody do it you love it keep doing
it and keep being consistent with it and
look look we're 50 years old I was doing
this [__] when I was 23 right that's
crazy you know yeah that's what that's
the Timeless aspect of it you know again
but it goes back you know you either
Inspire like if you go you go to a
football players baseball players's
mom's house you'll see him doing that
sport when he was 108 years old it's got
to be it's got to be passion yeah there
has to be passion first thing right it
can't be like chains the broads and the
cars well I mean I always tell people
like uh if you are willing to spend
money on a a belt or a [__] wallet or
a [__] half ass chain but your videos
look like [__] yeah and the artwork of
your album is a joke and you a and you
ain't doing social media content the
right way like [__] your belt Bro [__]
the Louis belt [__] the Gucci shoes I
always say that I you know it's
important like that the M that the
videos look the way the music sounds
yeah you got to Brand yourself you know
you got to re make everything look like
ice cream you want the cover to be right
you want your videos to be right like
right now everything I'm doing I'm
trying to take my time like even though
I don't do songs all the time but when I
do it now I want to make sure everything
is tight everything's looking right the
roll out's nice you know what I'm saying
um somebody who was I arguing with
somebody from San Francisco in my
comments
lied they said that what they say
somebody said the Bay has the best
Mexican food which is just the BAC lie
obviously cuz San Diego San Diego San
Diego got good Mex I ain't going to lie
not from San Diego I'm from Phoenix San
Diego San Diego has the best
Mexican I'm going take n no n I'm going
say n n n n n n San Diego's good San
Jose San ho got some good [__] though
too San Diego they neck and neck I'm
going say I'm going say neck and neck
San Diego San Jose man San Diego I'm at
to ride with San ho man 25 Market listen
San Diego got the craziest Mexican food
I ever had and well Tiana is my [__]
though there's a place in TJ called lion
fish that's oh so good but that's like
marisco is like more of the Spanish [__]
but more the the seafood [__] but n
you're crazy you're a liar I got
run if I was a liar I'd say Phoenix has
the best meic but it doesn't cuz San
Diego does San Diego's got the best
mexic right there I'm tell you drive 20
minutes be in Mexico I get upset about
being in Texas if they don't [__]
have burritos bro n man bro I don't
Texas I mean you'll find it Ain like a
burrito like a California Burrito who
are we arguing with from Texas to was it
OT I'm like you can't obviously have you
can't really think me like Texas Mexican
food is better than anything in
California I remember I remember one
time I was in Houston and I hit bash and
I'm like yo dog what's where do they
have roll tacos out here he sent me to
this spot and they're like dipped like
in sauce video no no no no no it was not
be it was it was just all bad no yeah
yeah listen Texas is own thing but it
ain't [__] with Cali it ain't [__]
with Az either Tucson Phoenix [__]
on Texas so n San Jose San Jose San San
San Diego 20 bit Mar I say this the best
Papas I ever had were off Mission oh in
the mission I had one of about 30th
Street oh my God were you there Cyrus
when we had papusas in the
bay oh man they were so good shout out
to the savis man I love papusas but yeah
look uh so we got an two albums coming
out two albums Cho El
Mexico go we working on something
together join join album then we got the
the song that he uh he wrote for you he
wrote for me right now wake up wake up
wake up featur Mary Wells you just help
put together the record with burner and
so we did burner I just did uh I had I
remixed burner Jay Diggs and two short I
threw Jenny 69 on there right Jenny did
her verse then I brought her up to the
Bay we just knocked out the video her
short burn
digs lit up the bay and that should be
dropping at the top of the Year yo what
um I always for people who I always say
people don't quite understand if you're
not
like so M Dre right right I've talked
with people in the bay that always say
that like he really wasn't fully
appreciated until he passed true he was
very much like that's what cu the radio
really got on him but everything just
really just intensifi but that really
happens with at all whatever I mean even
nipy do a standard right like nip wasn't
fully appreciate yeah I'm saying it's
just it's just what happens you know
what I'm saying people start really
listening to and appreciating what you
what the music you left behind it's just
crazy CU you think about like the hyy
era and how he really wasn't there to I
guess really enjoy the peak of it but he
was the one that started it he was the
light he was the fire he was the who
started it up but it's crazy cuz I just
like the like at the I guess you don't I
guess you don't appreciate this like you
don't appreciate things when they're
right there in front of you until
they're gone then you're like man but
we're here giving it up to him though so
for sure rip M Dre
man all right well look uh go stream
your song is out wake up people want to
sign up for some Dro they could go to
what you can go to my uh GT digital
distribution on IG there's a a click the
link in the bow or you can you you can
follow me at goto Link Link in the B on
IG just fill it out my staff's going to
get right to you we're going to sign you
up check you out you know listen to your
music and then uh we'll get you going
real easy you know what I mean and then
the show people people can buy tickets
yeah Chico music fest.com The Cho Music
Festival next year it's going to be
historical it's going San Diego stay
tune for all of it want to say I want to
say it's been a pleasure though U seeing
you uh you know develop yourself
apprciate it in an entertainment
business um and uh you know it's an
honor right now to be at this time in in
the rap game especially for Latin rap uh
you know right now it's the best it's
ever been yeah I mean it's we we are we
are at a point to where us as Latinos in
the entertainment business we have an
opportunity to really be great and to
come together to even be greater to help
each other because we I I believe we've
been held back a lot and um now is the
time to shine and to put our powers
together to be the best that we can be
and there's been there really dope media
platforms like food Community developing
and don't let no [__] stop you
man stop being scary get there and get
it done that's the [__] we doing feel me
that's it man I [__] standing on
this [__] there it is salute boom can we
show some love to our family at harden
man shout out to harden man look if
you're in Vegas you got to pull up you
got to say take me to harden right now I
need to go to harden they're going to
take you they're going to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Harding Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby